all right welcome everyone to brett
Weinstein's Dark Horse podcast i am
brett weinstein your host and I am here
sitting with Katie Herzog who is are you
still the second most hated author at
the stranger I would think that that's
true it's sort of a it's a
self-proclaimed identifier so there
haven't been a poll but judging from my
for my Twitter mentions I'd say probably
a second still second hate it I'm rising
in the ranks you're rising in the ranks
okay good
here's hoping you make it thank you the
pole position so welcome and thank you
for doing this yeah good to see you it's
great to see you we were on a panel
together last night with Heather huiying
where we talked about the necessity of
hate speech mm-hmm which was an
interesting interesting topic near and
dear to both of our hearts I would say
we both love hate speech Oh ma'am yeah
so I read on Twitter yes that's what
I've heard about us as well so tell me
what's on your mind these days oh gosh
what's on my mind these days politics as
usual I'm thinking a lot about the
Democratic race for president I'm
thinking a lot about how I think
Democrats are failing the Democratic
race for president and the media
establishment I'm thinking a lot about
how it seems like we learned very very
few lessons from 2016 and see my
destined to repeat the same errors so
that's what I'm thinking about me--don't
Democrats always mess up the race for
president I mean isn't that kind of
their role I Democrats do have a higher
barrier to success in Republicans I mean
the system is built to support rural
places the Electoral College you know
it's real but instead of acknowledging
that in dealing with the reality of
things like the electoral college the
Democrats just seem to do the same thing
which this year is you know the top
candidates are moving further and
further to the left's I think to appeal
to the media which is far more liberal
leftist than the voting populous so it's
really a catch-22 you know they have to
appeal to the sort of people like me who
work in the media these sort of
gatekeepers who determine whether or not
you get the attention required to have
the name recognition whether it's
required to win the primary
and then if they win the primary they're
dealt with or they have to deal with the
fact that you just you know came out for
non-binary driver's license or whatever
the thing is that's not going to appeal
to the you know the six districts in
Pennsylvania that are going to determine
who the next president is yeah and they
pivot to the right and they prove it to
the right so yeah so I have been quite
frustrated with the Democratic Party for
decades now and I remain nominally a
member of it because of the structure of
politics and the fact that one reduces
their say over the system if you walk
away from the major parties but I've
described myself as the most reluctant
Democrat and I do think that the 2016
election established that there is
enough momentum behind the idea of
breaking out of our paradigm that
something new could happen now which
wouldn't have been possible I'd say 15
years ago but I do wonder if we need to
actually do something to step away from
the Democratic Party and unfortunately
there is of course a walkaway movement
which is disguise for walking towards
the Republican Party which is certainly
no better but is there a play where
those of us who have seen substantive
change of the kind that we would desire
frustrated year in and year out for well
essentially the entirety of your life
and almost the entirety of mine
is there a move in which we actually
gain some influence over government and
move it in the direction of honorable
progressive policies I think we're
seeing right now the opposite happened I
think we're seeing a sort of we are
seeing a kind of revolution but it's a
revolution on going to the far left part
of the party people like aoc who has
sort of sucked all the attention out of
the room despite being a you know
freshman freshman congressperson
so I I don't know I'm maybe not as
optimistic as you are you know the
problem with the walkaway movement as
you mentioned is that you're walking
away from one thing and you're going to
something worse that's not a solution
and I have a lot of frustration with
with people like for instance des Rubin
who sort of it's maybe I agree with him
when it comes to the Democrats but his
solution said that seems to be pushing
two people to the right and I don't
think that's the solution so for me what
I would like to do it as I would like to
see people like us kind of old-school
liberals stand up and say that we don't
like the direction the party is taking
this is why we need to move it into a
place of going back to the sort of
classical liberal values of tolerance
for diversity of ideas free speech due
process but I'm not seeing that what I'm
seeing instead is people incredibly
frustrated by the sort of the locus of
the Democratic Party essentially
registering a [ __ ] you vote they're
gonna go vote for Donald Trump just to
say [ __ ] you to the Democratic Party
yeah which unfortunately I understand
more than I would like to I agree with
that
I spoke to it to a trump supporter a
former Democrat who considered himself a
lifelong Trump supporter a working-class
guy who voted for Donald Trump and I
interviewed him a couple weeks ago and
I'm gonna talk to him for the next year
until the election and check in and see
how this guy my goal is to change one
person's vote so I'm trying to change
this guy so and he explained to me it's
not about policy it was never about
policy he hated Hillary Clinton because
she was elitist she was condescending
and she called half the country
deplorable and it's so and he recognized
that this is counterproductive to his
own well-being because Donald Trump is
not actually fighting for the workingman
right but he hated Hillary Clinton and I
don't think people realize how strong
that is and maybe part of it's about
sexism maybe I don't know for whatever
reason people have hated her in
particular for the past thirty years and
that didn't change when she was running
for president obviously I mean I think
one of the problems Elizabeth Warren is
that she looks too much like Hillary
Clinton and they don't really look alike
but they sort of look like you know
sleep loosely well I must say I have a
very
visceral response to Hillary Clinton I
had the same response to Bill Clinton I
was never for one minute a Bill Clinton
fan there are things I found remarkable
about him I think he was very eloquent
and he did speak to something in people
but I just don't trust him and I just
don't trust her and the thing about
Trump is he did successfully muscle out
of the way the crime families that had
been holding us hostage for so long but
basically he's a new crime family right
and it's stupider one in a more corrupt
one I think or worse at this and much
more inclined to gamble big right which
you know he likes to gamble big take
credit when it works out and then he's
not gonna be left holding the bag for
when it goes south which it will so he's
not a viable answer to this question
right nor is he you know I just I think
he's just not up to the challenge of
thinking on behalf of other people right
and you know I wish he was and in fact I
will confess that the the night he was
elected where we were all stunned
because he you know whether you wanted
him to win or didn't want him to win we
all thought he was going to lose or
almost all of us did and then to
discover that he had won was just
totally stunning but I said to Heather I
said you know I'm not expecting it but
given the cards that he has if he wanted
to become the greatest president in US
history starting from this moment he
could do it right what he's done is he
has actually gotten through a style of
gatekeeping designed to keep anybody
like him out of the office and now if he
wanted to you know if he pulled off the
mask and did something visionary there'd
be no stopping him well do you think
that if even if he had people would be
happy about that I mean Trump has
occasionally done a couple of things
right yep
and the response of that isn't to like
pat him on the back it's a it's to
decide for anyone right right which I I
just find a counterproductive in a lot
of ways I mean things like sentencing or
where I'm granted he didn't do this out
of the goodness of his heart he did it
because the people pulling his strings
told him to do it yeah but still we
should say it doesn't matter who the
person is when the when the person in
power does a correct thing we should
encourage that well let's put it this
way if he had done it he would have had
whatever this thing is that is emerging
outside of the mainstream media the real
conversation of which this podcast is a
part of which your column for the
stranger is clearly a part whatever that
discussion is would have an Twp I
believe had Donald Trump revealed
himself to be a visionary maverick who
was not of the system that had held us
hostage there would have been a lot of
us who would have defended him that's
not what emerged obviously I don't
really think the person has it in him
and you know it's not out of personal
hatred that I feel like we have to get
him out of office it's just this is not
safe right
migrant although I do also really
[ __ ] hate him I'd hate him and I
would like totally admit that but I also
think that again that's part of the
problem like I work in the media I have
I'm very transparent about about my
feelings about Donald Trump but people
like me are all over the media ecosystem
and when he talks about fake news I mean
he took the term fake news he took this
very real thing and he distorted the
term he rebranded it and made it any
criticism of him yeah the truth is the
media is biased against Donald Trump I
mean no question about absolutely right
well so personally just the way I tick I
hate very few people right I have a very
strong negative reaction to the Clintons
but I wouldn't even call it hate it's
just like wait a second that's
influence-peddling that that's corrosive
to the very things that the country
needs to stand for and frankly I think
so in short I don't hate Donald Trump I
don't think it's productive it's not
productive in fact it's
counterproductive but with respect to
the Clintons the reason that I maybe
even feel more strongly about them is
that I my lifetime overlapped
a transition in left-leaning politics
and basically what I saw happened and I
know I've got a lot of pushback for for
this but what I saw happen
was a the Republican Party innovated a
kind of influence peddling and catering
to a corporate entity that did not have
our best interests at heart and it got
very good at it and instead of
challenging it the Democrats mimicked it
and they became the alternative so now
that we have two two flavors of
corporate rule and what got assured out
was the historical obligation that the
Democratic Party had to working people
to common people well if no party
represents common people you end up
where we are now and so the I guess the
problem that I have with the Clintons is
that they represent the Democratic Party
turning its back on working people and
now the Democratic Party is effectively
making the argument every single
election well who you gonna vote for the
Republicans you're gonna let them win
are you gonna vote for a third party
you're gonna hand this to the Republican
that it's like look how many elections
do you get to threaten me with the
Republicans winning before this is your
fault rather than mine right you decided
to make that bargain and want to become
popular there's a very easy
straightforward way to do it
start representing common Pete right
right yeah no I think you're right about
that I think that there are a lot of
forces to blame for Donald Trump winning
the election but I think the first one
should be the DNC in the Democratic
Party and Hillary Clinton was a terrible
candidate I was I was one of the few
people who thought that she was going to
lose because I'm from North Carolina I
don't know a wide variety of
conservative people but I sort of know
enough to know how people feel about
Hillary Clinton my girlfriend's parents
are Alaska and they hate they're very
Christian they hated Donald Trump they
still voted for him because they called
her a snake in the grass they're more
willing to vote for a man who has the
race like his values are actually less
in line with theirs than hers are in
some ways yeah but they were willing to
vote for him
they hated Hillary Clinton so much and
when I heard that to me it was just like
this is what's gonna happen
people hate her and she granted she won
the popular vote but it doesn't matter
it absolute is my and just the fact that
like so the first election I voted in
was Al Gore we know what happened there
Hillary Clinton we know what happened
there I just cannot see if the
Republicans continue to lose the popular
or lose the election after winning the
popular vote I think that this system
would have changed by now but the
Democrats are so ineffective that the
system continues to exist yeah well so I
have been toying with something I don't
know how to deploy it or what it even
becomes but you know when you at the
beginning of this discussion we're
talking about the left and the Democrats
catering to them I don't even see it as
the left I see it as people who have
co-opted the left who are being catered
to who don't even really know what they
want an extent that this is so well
intentioned it's it's a misunderstanding
of what left actually is and so what I
want to do is found what I call your
other left
right not that left your other left
right what is your other left well it's
founded on
yes classical liberal principles but I
think it goes you know classical liberal
has become a kind of a shield for people
who are right-of-center
right but have some some classically
liberal values and what I would like to
do is make a distinction which is we
actually do need progress we cannot stay
on this trajectory as much as we are
being very well served in the immediate
present a not all of us are being really
well served and be it's not stable it's
dangerous long-term it will come apart
and it will be a disaster so we have to
have progress and what I would like to
see is a very sober discussion of how
one moves forward without making the
classic errors that people on the left
tend to make where they see an
opportunity to make things better and
they don't understand that they also are
in danger of making things worse we need
to have that discussion
and anyway I'm this is a very strange
era to be in but one of the things
that's very positive about it is that it
is causing people to emerge into public
consciousness who I think under ordinary
circumstances would never be heard from
people who are very creative and dynamic
and I'm thinking of you actually in this
context very specifically that you you
know I don't know how many of my
listeners will be familiar with you a
lot of them but not all of them yeah but
you have done a great job of being true
to your liberal beliefs and I would say
you're like me quite far left while
being honest about what we don't have
straight over on the left and I think my
favorite thing about what you're up to
is the way you were wielding humor in
order to be able to save very
uncomfortable things thank you I think
it's wonderful thank you I appreciate
that but it's also you know AI think
this is actually probably an ancient
mode I mean in other words that we have
a mistress an adaptation yeah what is
humour right it's not some frivolous
thing to entertain you right right it's
way too deep for that and the the way it
functions is way too complex for that to
be the explanation so in part one it has
to be about is navigating stuff that you
can't come out directly write and so
causing people to have that kind of
whiplash they get at the moment in the
joke where they suddenly have the real
meaning revealed if they get the joke if
they get the joke right
well but even even the line between
those who do and don't get the joke
carries so much yeah meaning I mean how
horrifying is it to be in a room of
people when the joke is deployed and you
don't know why everybody is laughing
right right or you laugh when nobody
else does I mean those are that's a
disaster so yeah totally yeah for a good
reason
yeah it's an interesting hypothesis I
had never thought of humor as an Evelyn
as an evolutionary adaptation but I
suppose everything is you know in your
world
especially well what I would say and you
know I've deployed a little test for is
it it is the presumption that something
is an adaptation yeah and basically if
you have something that is complex that
persists over evolutionary time and has
a cost that could be reduced then you
know it must be paying at least that
cost and then some or it wouldn't stick
around so to me things like humor
consciousness religion music all of
these things are slam dunks their
adaptations that's not the hard question
mhm what could they possibly before
right that's a good question getting
late isn't that the isn't that the
answer that almost goes without saying
right right right
although I'm a LESBIAN so I don't know
how this that help humor deploy my humor
to uh to bed people who can never bear
my bear my children is really gonna help
me humans are weird
well human humans are so my advisor is a
guy named dick Alexander who was a
wonderful guy very funny
um he was he was very polarizing he was
well loved by people who liked him and
in my department he was despised by
people who had challenged him and lost
but anyway he Oh
sexuality uh no you're talking about the
fact that you were deploying humor
people who couldn't possibly write um
did you say barrier did yeah that's a
good one so anyway dick wrote a paper a
great one that was titled on the human
humans as the uniquely unique species
that's not the exact title but anyway
it's a great paper and the basic point
was that you know all species are unique
but humans are uniquely unique so when
you say that humans are weird you ain't
kiddin yeah we're the we are the kind of
species there is yeah there's something
I want to ask you about yeah so all
right so there's this replication crisis
and specifically in like social science
right yeah and all of these studies that
have been cited thousands of times
and are taken is sort of you just
believes to be true or it turns out
they're either not replicable or the or
the study was [ __ ] in the first place
yeah so the the latest one to come out
and sort of make a big splash
christina hoff sommers wrote a piece in
The Wall Street Journal about the blind
Orchestra study yep did you see this
maybe you can explain the study a little
bit better
well the blind Orchestra study basically
said that the number of women who were
hired into important positions in
orchestras went up dramatically when the
auditions were held behind a screen that
masked their gender right and it turns
out that this was not actually true
right so anyway you were gonna make more
just knowing about the replication
crisis okay so everything that's
happened in the past couple years
politically everything that's happened
through my own sort of personal to the
to the downsides of the laughs watching
what's happening with these replication
crises things like this my son with the
b2 movement my sense of what is real and
what is not real has become much
blurrier and and one there's one
particular Avenue where I find this the
most concerning and it's climate change
yeah because what I realized is that I
realized that I'm not a climate
scientist you know I don't actually know
I can look at the data and I wouldn't be
able to tell you what it says and be
like reading Esperanto I actually
probably read Esperanto better than I
could study on snow pack or whatever I
can trust scientists I I do trust
scientists I trust the scientific method
and I think the right method is a
4-story
right so there's a difference between
climate science and social science for
sure
but I still find myself saying like if
everything else that I thought was true
wasn't true what if this other thing
isn't true and it's really [ __ ] with
me I mean I wrote I covered client I was
an environmental reporter for years I do
believe in climate change but I also
don't believe I don't trust activists I
no longer trust activists and I know
that most of the information when I was
a climate reporter most of the
information I was getting was filtered
through activists you get press releases
from activists
everything's filtered through this sort
of political lens and I don't trust it
anymore I don't trust the apparatus I
don't trust the methodology and I'll
trust any of it but I still believe in
climate change so I'm just having this
like this sort of difficulty here like
what if that is also not true so this is
the real red pill yeah forget that
conservative [ __ ] this is real one yeah
we're about to mainline it yeah well but
you know I guess look at on the one hand
I actually viscerally feel your pain I
know exactly the revolution that you're
experiencing and boy is it frightening
yes on the other hand it's really
marvelous that you're there right
because the tiny number of people on the
other side of that thing need you right
so look you've pushed play on something
that has a lot of threads
let's explore them and then we'll see
where we end up mm-hmm eh this
replication crisis has nothing to do
with social science right no I'm ok with
it right what it has to do with is a an
opportunity and niche that exists inside
of academic science right social science
is maybe the most vulnerable to it
because the other things that compete
with this niche are less strong mm-hmm
all right so because social science is a
little bit iffy to begin with the
replication problem pulls harder right
it doesn't have a countervailing force
but you're gonna find this everywhere
that P values have been utilized and P
values have been utilized across science
and I should say I will pat myself on
the back for this one I was shouting
about this long before replication
crisis had ever arisen as a term right
the problem with p-values is that they
don't say nearly as much as you would
like them to say and so effectively what
they say is we have a pattern that we've
seen it has a strength
and that strength needs to be above the
level where we would expect
to see it by accidental random sampling
error and so what we want is a situation
in which 19 out of 20 times you wouldn't
get a pattern that strong by random
sampling error alright but 1 out of 20
you do now the problem is if I run a
bunch of studies and they don't get a
significant p-value and then I run
another study that's no better and it
does and I published that one right if I
don't you know published a negative yeah
right the point of the p-value actually
means nothing right worse than meaning
nothing what it does is it pseudo
quantifies our level of certainty which
we have no basis for so this has been a
a vulnerability from the beginning yeah
and what it means is we have no idea
that things that are based on p-values
unless you have information about
everything all of the work that was done
you don't know how to evaluate them and
then worse is even if you did have all
of the data of all of the studies that
were run and didn't come to anything and
never got published you wouldn't know
which ones of them were done well mm-hmm
so some of them may not have been
published because the people who did the
experiments felt like you know I didn't
quite right I think there was a flaw in
the way the data was collected
so they jettisoned those for good
reasons that's not real data but then
the other ones are real data so we have
no no basis to calibrate right our
journals less likely to publish a study
that has no sort of finding and of
course yeah of course because the
journals are in an economic competition
that is nowhere in the scientific method
right okay so this is God so basically
the work that find that the work that
would establish some baseline is not
being published and the only the only
thing that we're seeing is sort of
impressive values you're seeing a
sampling error of samples right right
seeing those samples that said X and not
those that said well this is happening
in the middle you where the job
prospects are artificially bleak in
science and the reason for that is
obscure all right the reason that job
prospects are bad if you get your PhD
you probably
we won't get a professorship the reason
for that is that the universities are
involved in a kind of con where they are
trying to get their classes taught on
the cheap so that they can free the
professor's to get grant right now the
reason that they want to do that is
because half of the grant money or more
goes to the university so that makes a
priority of free any professors from
teaching how do you free professors from
teaching I think a lot of graduate
graduate students right side you get a
lot of graduate students you make more
graduate students than there are jobs
which then puts them in more intense
competition when they graduate which
then results in them being much more
compromised ethically because they can't
say the true thing when the popular
thing is what's going to get you the job
so is this going to be in effect in
climate science unfortunately it can't
help it right
right right if you are going to try to
get a job in climate science and you're
gonna publish something that says wait a
minute maybe things aren't as bad as we
think you're gonna get crushed and so
the terrible fact here is that if
there's one thing we can be sure of its
that climate science as a social
endeavor is polluted by the same
perverse incentives that have polluted
social science and that that has a
blinding effect so we don't even know
what we're looking at right I mean it
makes total sense right this idea that
like that the world's gonna end in 12
years I sort of like to like to freak
people out cuz it's a little bit fun but
the reality is like there are
consequences to this you know like there
are kids in middle schools I'm told that
they're not gonna get to grow up to be
adults because because my parents
generation screwed them over or whatever
Exxon did it or whatever I just
psychologically what is this doing to
people well but like we haven't even
begun to go down the rabbit oh yeah yeah
because here's the thing it's not even
necessarily wrong that the world's gonna
end in 12 years it's not gonna end in 12
years if we extrapolate linearly or even
exponentially from where we are but
there is a pathway there that's very
direct which has to do with frozen
methane in the Arctic
of which there is a tremendous amount
and it needs to stay that way it needs
to stay frozen yeah right and the
problem is that there is likely a
threshold that we will cross where the
release of methane from the arctic well
so dwarf our contribution of the
atmosphere from burning fossil fuels
that this process will run away that
could happen this afternoon mm-hmm and
there's reason to think we might be
close to that threshold which is this is
the other side of the coin do we know
that the models that are being published
in climate science are reliable no we
can be pretty sure that there's a lot of
garbage there now it's possible that the
noise is dwarfed by the signal it's
possible that the models are good
they're just not nearly as good as we
claimed but it's also possible that the
models are really scarred and I would
say one thing that is important to
understand is that there is a I'm
constantly frustrated by the absence of
philosophers of science in our science
debates because there in some ways we've
we've paid to train them to navigate
some issues that are very important but
almost none of us understand one of them
in this case would be those models are
not actually good for testing anything
mm-hmm the system is too complex we
don't know enough about it to use them
as a test of what's going to happen but
we can use them to generate predictions
of what might happen which then can be
tested in the world itself so if we
could navigate that that boundary
carefully we could use the models and we
can find out how good they are but if
we're gonna use them to test ideas then
it becomes a delusion mm-hmm so the
question is if the models are suspect
which they have to be what do we do do
we say well this is you know all a bunch
of people right it's an aquiline
conspiracy it's a left-wing conspiracy
this that and the other I don't think so
I'm sure not where I come out yeah I
come out is first of all there are other
things that aren't model-based that
ought to
alarm us mhm the retreat of glaciers for
example that's something you can see
with your own eyes it does not require a
model even more frightening I would say
is the discovery on the Yamal Peninsula
and Siberia of these new craters you
know about them no I don't know why the
images of these things are not among the
most famous images on earth but the
story is that some petroleum workers
were flying over this Peninsula of
tundra Peninsula in in Siberia and they
spotted a giant crater that was new and
then they found another one and the
question is well what process did that
we don't even have a name for what
process did that did you know meteor of
hit it or what right
the hypothesis emerged that these were
explosive releases of methane that had
ejected a vast amount of rock from these
giants holes in the ground and that
would of course be alarming because what
we're talking about is the explosive
release of methane and so we've seen
things in the ocean where we've seen
plumes of methane bubble up that appear
to be unprecedented we don't really know
what they mean because nobody took
baseline data 50 years ago so we don't
know if blooms of methane bubbling up
should alarm us or shouldn't but it
certainly is consistent with our alarm
but these these craters on land the
prediction was well if these are methane
release craters than methane ought to be
highly concentrated in the bottom of
these things and you know people went in
and there was super high concentrations
of methane so you could make an argument
one way or the other but my basic point
would be look the links in the chain
that tell us to worry about climate are
actually more secure than people think
they have nothing to do with models they
have to do with some very simple
chemistry that tells us that things like
carbon dioxide and methane trap heat
right um which is you know that's a very
long-standing grandfather says
well-established easy to demonstrate in
the lab and then we
that glacial retreat and things like
that and then we've got novel geology
we've got you know rock being ejected by
explosive releases of methane which is
consistent with sudden releases of large
amounts of this stuff that are frozen in
the Arctic all of that stuff tells me
you had best worry yeah and what's more
the threshold at which this is no longer
a problem that humans could plausibly
deal with it could be anywhere right we
could cross it today right also could
have crossed it could have crossed it oh
yeah right yeah fifty years agos
unlikely we have seen spectacular rises
in temperature of a kind we haven't yet
seen but in any case here's the
overarching place that I think those of
us on your other left on a autoland
mm-hmm the climate crisis is not a
problem in and of itself it is a symptom
of another problem that doesn't have a
name and my point would be we have to
solve the underlying problem we know
that we have to solve it and you know
it's like that cartoon you know what if
we solve the world's problems to fix the
climate and it turns out it was just a
hoax and we made it better for no reason
or anything like that
it's still better it's still better and
that serves everybody I don't care if
you're a conservative or liberal I don't
want to see us crash an economy over it
but I don't think that's what happened I
thank you would actually stimulate an
economy for the same reason that a war
stimulates an economy a direction right
industry a concerted effort to solve the
problem with an unofficial yeah but the
underlying problem is one of chronic
unsustainable is where we are addicted
to any process that makes a profit and
at the point we discover why it can't be
sustained it can't be reversed do you
think there's some evolutionary
explanation for this for instance our
ancestors chimps you know [ __ ] off of a
of a limb or whatever and don't have to
deal with with their own byproducts of
their own pollution I think it's it's
worse than that a little bit there's you
know and in
difference a lack of understanding of
the consequences of our behavior but
worse than that we are the descendants
of winners every single one of us right
in fact every single one of us is the
product of an unbroken line of
reproduction that stretches back three
and a half billion years so as much as
being a winner is a pretty rare thing we
heard that all the winnings Jo it's rare
but we're at all of us right so what
were our ancestors doing well one thing
they were doing was they were not
foregoing the use of resources that they
had acquired mm-hmm right there was a
tendency to capture that which could be
captured and to turn it into something
in motion and frankly that can be bad
lots of populations have done themselves
harm and in some cases gone extinct
because they over exploited a resource
but in general you know before
industrialization it wasn't that
dangerous right there was only so
rapidly that people could you know
DeForest the Amazon if they were using
hand tools right all right so a sort of
self-limiting now it ain't right
I mean have you seen some of these
videos of these machines yeah stripped
trees yeah and that's another thing that
like you know soy I live in western
Washington you live in Oregon lots of
walking around here and there's this and
I think there is more I think I'm
speculating here but I think that
logging has uptick since Trump came in
office and there's this idea that you
know you can sort of sell it to people
as a job provider it's not a job
provider it's the one dude with a button
yeah you know there's this is not you
don't see it's eventually uh you know
logging trucks will be automated too so
there's not that's not going to provide
to people with jobs you there's just
this sort of slash-and-burn it's
incredibly depressing
- just like drive around these you know
sort of beautiful forests and see
they've all been decimated Oh see
they've all been decimated except that
they were decimated in a way there was a
computer program as I understood it that
actually would predict what a particular
clear cut would look like from various
places that it could be observed right
so they have a screen
you know right so Orion has that
Washington doesn't have that that
curtain as much so you can actually see
it but like it yeah if you're driving
from Portland out to the out to the
Oregon coast they make sure that you can
not you can only see the old-growth on
the side of the road ya know it's like
blinders but they're on the road instead
of on you're good yeah it's very sad
yeah I've taken a I've tried to take
this sort of a really long view on
climate and on on sustainability because
humans are destroying the planet that's
undoubtedly clear but ultimately if you
take the really long view it ultimately
doesn't really matter you know like you
know thirty million years ago
Arizona was an ocean or I'm making up
the time if you if you stop caring about
humanity so I try to be sort of
nihilistic about it eventually the earth
will recover any different in different
in different ways perhaps in mine it's
not gonna be the pristine globe that it
once was you know when when humans
disappear all it was a nuclear base will
melt down and this dance will need to be
torn down and all of those things this
is why I'm a this is why I'm in the
voluntary human extinction movement
because I think if we took a couple
generations torn down dams decommission
nuclear power plants and sort of
gradually fade it off you know we leave
the planet for another species to rise
and destroy and we'll just continue to
happen well please take whatever efforts
that you will put into voluntary
extinction very low effort very low
effort that put them into stable dry
cask storage for all of that nuclear
waste yeah because that's a problem it's
a real problem and people don't realize
how significant it is but looks
ultimately no one gets out alive right
there's no escape freedom and even if we
escaped the earth the galaxy is gonna
crash into the neighboring galaxies even
if we escape that disaster you don't
escape the heat death of the universe so
ultimately there's no point on the other
hand you could say the same thing about
your own life sure you are
and yet here and yet here you are having
a conversation I bet you're even going
to take your next breath even though it
will take my no there's no philosophical
justification for it I will take my next
breath but I will not have children
although it's so not well guess I don't
want
I mean that's surreal so that's the real
answers that they don't want them but I
can sort of I can sort of pose it as
this heroic like you know I don't want
to contribute to overpopulation blah
blah blah at the same time I will not be
adopting children either because I still
don't want children yeah I like to sleep
in I don't want plastic oh I don't want
to step on Legos it's a it's purely
aesthetic
yes well I'm a parent and I suffer from
the delusion that it's marvelous yeah
and the world needs more children with
parents like you but to the extent that
you don't want kids don't have them yeah
but the fact that you're going to take
your next breath mm-hmm please the lie
to the idea I mean we could just wait
see still breathing yep all right so
that puts the lie to the idea that it's
really okay to let humanity run its
course well for the individual right so
but for the future generations that
don't exist I don't think there's
anything inherently sort of tragic about
that
oh there kind of is maybe a poetic way
let's put it this way I know I'm gonna
die I know Humanity is gonna go extinct
and it doesn't diminish my desire to a
see what I can make of the short period
of time that I have on the planet that's
an amazingly cool game and I also think
that philosophically speaking there is
sort of an objective that I think if we
all thought really clearly and talked to
each other and you know spent a few
years getting getting it sorted out I
think there's a thing that we would land
on that's actually like the moral
imperative right the singular top moral
imperative and I know a person who says
such a thing has to be kind of crazy but
because life is cool we are more or less
obligated to see how many human beings
we can give that experience yeah I guess
I mean it's a pretty utilitarian
argument yes except you have to be
careful with it because that does not
mean let's see how many people we can
get on no equality right might order for
it to be quality in order for it to
really liberate us to do cool amazing
stuff
the population has to be low enough a
rate of consumption has to be
sustainable all of that but if we could
do that if we could stabilize the earth
so that there is no expiration date on
humanity sure right then how many people
are we giving this marvelous gift of hey
you know what you're gonna get
85 cool years in which to see what you
can create it's the most amazing video
game there ever was you know you can
build you can create insight art
whatever you want to do that's a that's
a wonderful gift to give to people and
to give up on humanity is to deny it to
an indefinitely large number of people
downstream of us I agree with that but
there is also a truth it's also true
that life is also suffering I mean
suicide is one of the the highest causes
of deaths in the Western world you know
so life is cool but life is also
terrible um well let's unpack that a
little bit hmm there is suffering in
life life wouldn't make any sense if
there wasn't some right each individual
has to face a certain amount of
suffering in fact suffering is clearly
an adaptation oh yeah yeah hazard yeah
um that does not mean that intolerable
levels of suffering of the kind that
cause people to kill themselves are okay
or even they were stuck with them right
so the thing I'm imagining that we're
sort of obligated to pursue is a world
in which nobody has to face that kind of
despair mm-hmm right yeah so you're
talking a real low population here not
necessarily you know look if I was if I
was dictating the course I would say
look we've gotten to a place where
almost everything can be done
electrically okay so let us shift to
electric why well number of reasons one
it's healthier at the point that you're
involved in the activity right electric
cars don't pollute they don't get asthma
all that now do they flew somewhere sure
at the coal plant but the more important
point is if you get everything run
electrically then you pursue fusion
power mm-hmm
and the thing is fusion power actually
allows us
to figure out what it's not the natural
carrying capacity that existed before
fossil fuels we might be able to set a
carrying capacity it could be quite a
bit higher right it could be three or
four billion people right and they could
live at a very high quality of life and
if you've made everything electric then
at the point fusion energy becomes
viable actually you can take all the
stuff that you're already using and just
plug it into a different source and
suddenly you've reached a potentially
sustainable alternative mode for human
existence and so the way I see this we
are up against the wall with respect to
the unsustainability crisis fossil fuels
being one manifestation of that but far
from the only one but we are you know
we're standing on one edge of a gap the
other edge of the gap is the point at
which we figured out how to do something
l elegantly with electricity and how to
fuel it ultimately with fusion power
right but it's also a political issue so
even if it's a technological fix I mean
you have both Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren one of you might be our
next president talking about not just
not building any more nuclear plants
decommissioning the ones that we already
have oh I want them to get decommission
so you want okay so so take everything
all of the existing nuclear do you can
mention that and just use a dead end
yeah and [ __ ] is a deadly dead end right
it's a Faustian bargain of the worst
kind mm-hmm Fusion is a whole different
ballgame mm-hmm right for many different
reasons one it doesn't have the risk of
meltdown it doesn't create the fuel this
long-standing spent fuel that we still
have no idea what the hell to do with
why can't we just take it up in the sky
and and dismiss it
Oh launch it into the side unless that's
a great idea except for one problem
which is that launching stuff into space
a and B it doesn't work all that well
things blow up and we would enter how
about we take it to the moon and launch
it from the moon well you got to get it
to the moon okay so look this is not a
bad idea if you could generate a fission
power in space beam it into the
atmosphere safely which I don't know
that we know that we could
possible even if you could put the
reactors in space beam the energy down
that you would end up ionizing the
atmosphere anyway that would be the next
devastating crisis but if you could do
fission power in space and then launch
the products into the Sun I'm all for
yeah yeah it's not that I'm against
fusion feasible it's just not safe
fusion still has a branding issue they
may want to stop calling it nuclear I
mean it's just it seems it sounds like
the same thing yeah except boy am I
going to love being its champion so is
this gonna be small reactors and people
like micro micro grids or whatever do
you picture this as like actually large
large vision or large fusion reactors
none they don't have to be immense but
it's not you don't get up your personal
fusion reactor as far as we know you
know if you know the unfortunately
fusion is gonna lead us to cold fusion
which is a morass um because for lots of
reasons probably there is no cold fusion
but it ain't as settled as people think
but anyway I'm talking about hot fusion
but the nice thing among the nice things
about hot fusion is that as soon as your
hot fusion reaction stops abiding by the
rules of your machine it shuts itself
it's dead Yeah right which is quite the
opposite with vision right vision it's
like and you have to have you have to
Menken maintain control over it and the
minute you lose control or the water
evaporates or whatever right the amount
of water you have to pump through to
keep it cool enough not to melt down as
isn't mass so anyway fusion power may
have and in fact what I always say is
nuclear power isn't one thing it's two
opposite things right and fusion power
is the one we should be betting on on
for anyway the nuclear power industry is
really the fission industries right
right they're not backing it right and
the fossil fuel industry obviously has a
tremendous amount to lose right um okay
well where have we ended up I feel I
feel reassured that climate change is
happening and less optimistic about the
future than I did 10 minutes ago Paso so
I feel both better and worse well okay
so
let me suggest an approach
philosophically here first of all let me
just point out something I've called the
activists dilemma which is that about
half the people are motivated by their
fear of what's going to happen if we do
nothing and half the people are
motivated by hope about what we might
accomplish and you can talk to either
group in isolation with no problem but
if you try to talk to them at the same
time you're always at cross-purposes
with yourself and it never goes well
so the fear that you are describing that
maybe it's too late maybe the problem is
too big maybe you know maybe you're
gonna live to see the end of this right
right
that's an abyss mm-hmm and I think you
know you and I don't know each other
that well but my guess would be that you
want to spend a little bit of time
staring into the abyss and make your
peace with that yeah right yeah cuz at
the point that you realize you know what
we've already miss played our cards
we're in very serious danger and this
will probably it's probably not rescue
about but I don't know it's not rescue
well and if we did rescue it that would
that's a noble thing to dedicate
yourself to while you're here and it's
pretty exciting right it's you know it
fits the superhero ethos of the moment
right to sort of say well [ __ ] we
actually do have to save the earth and
you know we have to figure out how to
take the tools we've got and address
that problem and you know well what do
you think about you know people like
Jeff Bezos saying like what have you say
the only way to deploy in my wealth
would be to send it to space you know
this idea that what or Elon Musk's this
idea that what we need to be doing is
colonizing Mars and uninhabitable planet
rather than deploying our resources to
save the one that we already have yeah
it's nonsense
it's nonsense it's not yes and it's not
that I don't understand what they're
saying and I you know this pains me a
little bit
my brother has a version of this too
which is we've got to break the the
speed of light speed limit that limits
us because it's keeping a
from getting to places we might actually
be able to persist which in principle I
don't disagree with but but we are not
going to send people anywhere faster
than the speed of light any time in the
foreseeable future man send a message
right across the galaxy that would reach
the other side
you know while anybody alive was still
alive that would be a miracle in and of
itself right right and the message would
probably be like you up but in any case
I think there are a lot of escapist
fantasies and the problem is that a some
of these escapist fantasies are probably
serving a purpose to a point in other
words I am sure that if you were to
unpack my internal program what's
driving me this you know there's spackle
in some places it's not perfectly worked
out and logical such that it all stands
up to scrutiny but it doesn't it's not
its purpose right its purpose is to make
sure I get up in the morning and do the
stuff that needs doing right and you
know it's a little bit like our visual
understanding of our world you know it's
got heuristics all over the place by and
large they keep you from crashing into
[ __ ] right right so that's good these
stories may be doing that job for
certain people but my fear is that when
Elon Musk talks about colonizing Mars
people take him serious right and it's
not that getting to Mars is impossible
it's not that it's even inconceivable
that you could colonize it but it's not
in the immediate offing no matter how
goodie I don't even see this desirable I
mean I saw that movie with Matt Damon
like he like he has to use his own [ __ ]
to fertilize his potatoes like we just
we have a miraculous planet I mean
that's where I sort of see the most hope
and the most sort of fear is I spend a
lot of time in nature and it's stunning
and you and I live in one of the most
beautiful parts of the country and it's
I'm sort of remarkably I'm blown away
every day every when I take my ferry
ride blown away by the mountain
and the landscape around me and at the
same time I'm just so depressed about
what is happening to this much more I'm
much more depressed about the state of
the planet about pollution and
sustainability than I am sort of what's
happening socially in some ways well you
know in the answer to how you address it
has to be philosophical you got to find
a way to make your peace with the cosmic
joke you are on the greatest planet that
we are aware of it is being degraded but
it's still absolutely marvelous and at
every scale you know I mean look into
moss or the microscope and ya see
amazing stuff yeah
and so there's plenty this is a tragic
moment but it is also a moment at which
your life matters a lot because what
happens next is uncertain and I think
everybody is going to need to find their
individual way to make peace with the
absurdity and the horror and the
possibility of this moment but having
done so you sometimes I call myself an
accidental Buddhist because although
I've never studied Buddhism I'm not a
religious person by nature I feel like
many of the thoughts if you push them
far enough that's where they end up
bright in that neighborhood and I think
there is a kind of there's a kind of
enlightenment once you realize what this
moment is and how improbable you are and
how improbable it is that you would land
in this moment and be aware of what it
was and actually potentially have some
influence over it because people listen
to you or something like that well I
call it the cosmic joke right I mean
it's a very funny joke in a way that you
would end up in that odd situation and
it does potentially give meaning to
every day
yeah do you if you could go back and
tell yourself you're you know from 10
years ago or whatever you know 10 years
from now you're not gonna be teaching
anymore but you'll be a sort of public
figure would you have been surprised by
this in truth yeah no I sort of feel the
same way about myself I feel like I
don't believe in fate anything like that
I don't believe in predestination I've
always thought and I've done very little
work to like actually get myself to this
position but I've always that like
there's one paper I want to work for and
I work for it I didn't do that much work
like you know I did where I did work
it's not like it's totally stumbled in
this but there have been this sort of I
don't know a series of happenstance
things that have happened to put me in
this position not getting some jobs
getting some jobs that it once seems
incredibly random and also totally
inevitable yeah yeah I think there's a
couple of reasons for that one it might
be that this is one of these heuristics
that you sort of need to think that
otherwise you'd spend a lot of time
trying to figure out how the hell this
happened to you right but no I I sort of
feel like everything that led up to this
was a an oddly perfect training camp
right like I I got to see this in
microcosm before it suddenly became
large-scale and anyway it does feel
oddly natural mm-hmm
I feel like an odd person for the job
right I feel like looking from the
outside it'd be a bit of a
head-scratcher but from the inside yeah
it feels it feels feels right if yeah
yeah but also tear it's also terrible
but also right you know well but I mean
you know the circumstances that have led
us to being in the positions that we are
in are not necessarily positive ones for
the culture they are not right they are
not on the other hand you know and
you're the type specimen for this but
the number of really fascinating truly
decent people that I have been put into
contact with by what happened
is stunning and the just the fact of
being able to participate in the
conversations that matter is you know
it's a privilege it's delightful most
days and so anyway I mean you one could
one could exert a lot of skepticism at
it but I'm not sure I'm not sure why I
think yeah thing is this is a very odd
thing to have happened but do you have
any is there one sort of belief that has
changed for you since all this happened
something that you're very shocked to
realize that you now believe it's true
or something that you didn't that you
did believe and now don't that's a good
question and I wish I had a really
compelling answer for it I would say I
have been surprised by some people who I
otherwise would have dismissed telling
other words periodically I encounter
somebody who I would have guessed was
just dangerous and broken and then you
talk to them and it turns out they're
actually on about something that's real
and yeah that sort of thing yeah I've
had similar experiences and I think you
and I have also had a similar experience
and I'm never invited on left-leaning or
even mainstream like media shows I did
the gist which is a slate show but
that's but it's hosted by Mike Pesce
who's sort of a heterodox thinker but
I'm in convert I'm on podcast
conservative podcast every week or shows
like this that are more heterodox
never never like I've been on NPR a
couple times what those invitations have
really driven that really dried up yeah
and that's surprising to me yeah but I
think it really tells us were yeah yeah
um and you know I don't hate it I sort
of think it comes down to people like
you and me who can tell that story and
just say look the left didn't show up
right this other thing did it's the true
level and you don't know it unless
you've been paying attention to certain
quadrants but but it's the real deal I
find it problematic in the sense that to
borrow a phrase from our STW friends I
find it problematic in a sense that I
would like to I would like the things
that I believe to be reaching a wider
audience of not just conservatives and
heterodox figures who are probably more
inclined to you know believe me and
trust me in the first place you know I
would like to be reaching an audience
that is of the left and disagrees with
me in a way that we could have some
constructive dialectic but it doesn't
happen they don't want to engage I think
it is happening and I think the problem
is that we have a wrong story in our
heads about what to expect about the way
people change their minds and broaden
their minds and so I see a slower game
where you say something you get mocked
or crushed or whatever it is that
happens but in that some number of
people have changed their minds and the
point is the next time you confront that
same thing the dynamic unfolds
differently in a way you can't detect is
the result of what happened the first
time but it is right right and so as you
and I've talked about I felt very much
like there was a deliberate attempt to
throw me out of the left because it was
very inconvenient for people who were
self-described left us to have me around
I own a same thing is true for you
there's a point at which you don't
accept the offer of okay now you've been
read pilled now you're a conservative
right you keep saying no yep same
liberal I was I'm not backing down
you know I'm listening to arguments I'll
grow if I've missed something but I'm
not backing down because I'm unpopular
on the left right right and that has an
effect mm-hmm people see it and they
listen and so you know on Twitter for
example sometimes you'll say something
and you'll get a ton of pushback like
mean pushback but you'll also get a huge
number of likes
like you can track these things almost
separately the pushback is the reply
it's tricky
yeah it's designed to you know to
penalize you for saying something out
loud and then the likes because they're
cheap and they're not totally anonymous
but they're close if you've got a large
number of them they're actually an
indication Oh heard yeah yeah yeah yeah
this I interviewed a yachtsman Mohammed
the other day who's excellent next
Muslim atheist brave incredible thinker
and his new book out and an Amazon has
declined to to allow her to purchase ads
for her book so they're selling the book
but she can't place an ad for the e-book
because according to Amazon her book is
controversial so wait they're
Islamophobia phobic their Islamic of it
yeah yeah and so I started out this
piece about Yasmin and we had a you know
a great conversation and she brought up
something that I found incredibly
telling which was you know megan phelps
from the Westboro Baptist Church also
has a book out right now she's been on
fresh air she's been on Morning Edition
she's been on Good Morning America she's
been all over the media ecosystem and
she is viewed as a survivor and a hero
totally yeah so Muhammad who was
arguably treated worse under Islam than
Megan Phelps was under her
fundamentalist Christian cult you know
she's not a hero she's not a survivor
she's not a victim she's an apostate or
an islamaphobe or a racist
that's a beautiful parallel it's insane
and it's so obvious when you see it you
know it's so obvious and obviously sam
harris and other people have been
talking about this for years that any
you know criticism of Islam is
considered racist however that you can
criticize Judaism of Christianity that's
totally fine anyway so I wrote this
piece about it interviewed Osman and I
and I don't often read the comments on
my on my post for the stranger because
it's not a construct abuse of my time
but I did I read the comments cuz I want
him to see what you know what people's
out of her and the peace and the first
one was you know I'd said something like
Herzog when are you gonna go work for
the Daily Caller and this idea that
because I object to the beating of
children
the oppression of women all over the
world that somehow is a conservative
value is just what yeah like how did we
get to this point it blows my mind
it's everything I'm talking about is
liberal values yeah freedom
you know independence fighting the
actual patriarchy and I'm not talking
about this American version of the
patriarchy which is man splitting and a
you know mythical wage gap I'm talking
about real [ __ ] patriarchy here and
that somehow is a conservative value to
push back against that so first of all I
resonate with everything you just said
do you have the experience you must have
the experience of you get that nasty
voice that's trying to cause you
self-doubt or it caused you to think
that your being that you appear
loathsome in the eyes of outsiders or
something like that but you must also
get people defending you oh for sure for
sure and it's one of those things where
it's like you know you don't think of
the defense you know you remember that
you remember the one tweet from it from
an anime avatar for if somebody had
never heard of you know who probably
doesn't exist it's probably a bot or
whatever like you think of the one you
remember that you remember the hate and
not the praise I mean my I do get I do
get a lot of support I've also found
that support often comes privately and
you might have had this experience as
well the support is emails the hatest
weeds yeah although first of all as you
point out and I don't think just because
it's some account that may not even be a
real person that it doesn't matter I
think those are there to steer the
conversation and so what they're you may
blanch at something but the idea is
they're trying to steer the conversation
about what you're saying so that it
lands on certain things it so it's
always ad hominem yeah well here's one
so I get in trouble there's certain
topics which I get in trouble on one of
them has to do with my view of sex and
the way it is unfolding in in Western
civilization I have the sense that we
are treating sex very frivolously so it
doesn't exist
no I'm talking about
sexual attraction wait and my point
would be more or less this is really
powerful stuff and we are treating it in
an incredibly frivolous way so you're
talking about online dating swiping that
pornography that kind of yeah I'm anti
porn
I'm anti casual sex hmm I think I'm very
Pro sex I think and I think it's very
powerful stuff but it should be treated
with respect
same way actually I feel about
hallucinogenic drugs which is these
things are power tools I encourage
people who think that they should be
experimenting with them to try it but I
would encourage you not to think of them
as recreation mm-hmm right so it's sort
of that sort of thing but what comes
back at me of course on the sex front is
that I'm a prude right we're worse right
conservative that I meant in so ah yes
right which I find this is just an
amazing accusation because whatever else
you can say about me you have two
children not only do I have two children
I'm still married to their mother and
people stopped me on the street and they
tell me that I've married up yeah which
I agree right but okay so I'm at least
not an insult but I think the idea is
I'm not gonna buy this it's a weird
insult because it just doesn't have any
content but but if you point at me and
you accuse me of being an insult than
other people who maybe don't know who I
am or don't know who I'm married to or
write you off right well a in cell is
like it's a really grotesque category
right it has the stigma to it and so if
you can just get that stigma to land
nearby something then people like oh I
don't want any part of that so what do
we do about the fact that these
conversations are being steered around
us with you know I don't know what those
accounts are there's a particular
signature that I look for when somebody
throws something at me that's
particularly awful pronouns and bio is
that a significant it's not that the one
I see is
and it's a weird one it's they follow a
bunch of people like let's say they
follow 700 people they are followed by a
tiny number of people 150 something like
that
there in general not followed by anyone
I know and the account is old mm-hmm
right they registered in 2012 mm-hmm
what an old account that has 40
followers so not someone who
participates that much well the thing is
I was puzzling over this because if it
was a new account I would know what was
going on somebody registered a new
accounts and is using them to steer
conversations but an old account would
well I wonder what's the average number
of followers had I mean there I don't
know how many millions of people are on
Twitter but I would assume that the
average father account is probably
pretty low well the average home owner
accounts pretty low but you wouldn't
expect somebody who follows a ton of
people to have a low follower account
after a long period of time right unless
they're terrible at Twitter which is
right also possible well a friend of
mine who is sophisticated about this
sort of thing made the argument that
what these are are old dormant accounts
that had easy passwords that have been
hacked by some huh that is using them to
steer conversations which actually
strikes me as very plausible interesting
yeah that seems I that seems a little
conspiratorial to me in the sense that
like a lot of I know who my haters are I
don't know who they really are but I
know like theirs so the stranger we have
a fairly vibrant comment section and
it's not nearly as vibrant as it was you
know before social media took when when
blogging was at its height there would
be a post with one line and there would
be 200 comments or whatever so we don't
have that but we do have a community an
ecosystem for sure and the same name
show up and I can sort of I know who's
who I know who doesn't like me because
they were super [ __ ] obvious about it
quite is why I stopped reading the
comments I also I did something recently
I turned off notifications from people
who don't follow me and it has changed
the conversation it has changed my
Twitter experience from one of dread
so one of just it's it's all positive
because the only people who respond are
people who follow me already they
already they presumably don't hate me
they're willing to follow me and I feel
a little guilty about that because I've
I believe in open dialogue I don't think
that criticism is cancellation I do want
to be sort of open to you know to
legitimate good-faith criticism but I
also am sick of [ __ ] hearing it yeah
you know and not the good faith
criticism I'm sick of hearing at hominem
attacks and so for me to sort of
function as a as a person in the world
if I have something that's coming out so
it's going to be controversial or if
there's been something grand about me or
whatever I just turned off you know I'm
mute notifications from everybody
doesn't follow me and all just
disappears which is a pretty remarkable
feature of the of the platform that you
can just the criticism is there
I just shielded myself I've made my own
personal echo chamber and I realized
there are consequences to that well I
think that this is a an unsettled
question for all of us who inhabit this
landscape so there are people like Dave
Rubin Sam Harris and others who have
tuned out the criticism right entirely
Dave muted me giddy
oh yeah after I I mean granted I was
being a huge pain in his ass because I
was trying to get him to respond to a
piece that I wrote in response to
something he said I mean I had written
you know a thousand words about this
this wasn't a personal attack or
anything they don't he I'm pretty sure
me too because I've tweeted it at home
like every day for like a week trying to
get his attention it failed well I
understand I mute people all the time
well but here's the thing right you have
to understand dave has deployed a filter
that is very intense in part because
what comes out after him is quite
intense
yeah and largely unfair yeah I'm not
saying that there's not a critique to be
level and I've leveled against him not
against him but to him multiple times
but some of what he gets is just
tremendously mean and unfair and not
decent right so we all have to set the
slider somewhere are we gonna listen to
nothing from the landscape are we gonna
listen to
everything which is bewildering in and
of itself or are we going to go it
somewhere in between every place you set
the slider has significant costs mm-hmm
I think you'd be a fool to set it all
the way in one direction or the other
and it doesn't sound like that's what
you've died but how you how you filter
what you hear so that the critique that
you need to hear gets through and the
critique that you maybe can't afford to
take seriously because it's not legit
and it's designed to to tie you in knots
right how you sort between those things
is a little bit of an art form and it's
also a moving target because whatever it
is that's trying to get to us whether
it's individuals who are just trying to
get into our heads or it's something
more organized than that that wants to
do away with the alternative
conversation it is trying out new
stratagems all the time and so I don't
know exactly what to say but I will say
there you unread it at all I I don't
post I look at some Larssen yeah yeah I
do more lurking on reddit than anything
but I've noticed that subreddits go
toxic mm-hmm right Sam Harris a
subreddit has gone absolutely toxic
toxic left is it so it's just infighting
among his fans or is this infiltration
of people who don't like Harris in the
first place
I think so I think there are two Sam
Harris subreddits and one of them has
been effectively captured by some woke
something or other
mm-hmm and it just impossible have a
conversation but the point is I don't
think Sam necessarily knows that because
I don't do it right and the problem is
it is having some effect on how Sam is
understood in the world right that Sam
cannot navigate because he's unaware
right and anyway I think all of us are
in some danger so I don't know where to
set the slider but yeah that it is a
slider is important yeah it's
interesting every online subculture that
I've observed has turn toxic every one
knitting mushroom hunting podcasts you
know fans of murder podcast or whatever
at some point a community that seems you
know supportive and just there for the
love of the thing always turns toxic and
I don't know why that is if there's
something particular about about online
discourse or the moment that we're in or
a human you know the nature of what it
is to be a human in general but I just
see it over and over again every every
Facebook page every you know there's
they'll be a they'll be a group the
group will will splinter off because
there's too much infighting in the main
group and then that group lasts for a
little while and then that group falls
apart because there's too much
infighting in that group it just seems
to be a feature I wonder so Eric said
something I forgotten where he said it
but publicly he said something about the
necessity to to have a degree of elitism
and it was badly misunderstood by people
I know exactly what he was saying it had
to do with the necessity to restrict
conversations to those who are ready to
have them and take them seriously sure
right and I think the problem you're
pointing to is that every online
discussion a there's a kind of social
entropy phenomenon where it's much
easier to disrupt a conversation than it
is to build one and so how long can a
conversation exist before something gets
into it that just ties it in a knot yeah
the only antidote would be a force that
allowed you to bar more gatekeeping
yeah and more gatekeeping yes then does
have an elitist problem which is you
know want to bar people from the
conversation who are heterodox right
right so anyway that's an unsolved
problem but I do think we're suffering
from too much gatekeeping in some places
and too little gatekeeping in others
yeah I would agree with that yeah
serious problem mm-hmm so I heard you
say something on the panel last night
which reminded me of something I've
heard Heather say and I think it makes
sense for us to talk about here you said
that because you were a tomboy that
you're afraid that if you were young in
this era that you might find yourself
pushed towards transitioning and that
that would be a regrettable right so I
so I think that I think that I would
have if I were 15 years old right now
and I was online and the people around
me were transitioning or saying or
non-binary whatever I think I would be
one of them I was you know sort of the
new narrative is that if you are a girl
who likes quote/unquote boy things if
you have short hair and like the color
blue and play sports I was the only girl
in Little League I was that kid then
you're not a girl you're a bit you're a
literal male and I think I would have
been captured by that that said I also
happen to be the child of a man who
taught human sexuality and evolutionary
psychology for 30 years and who is very
familiar with the what the work of
Michael Bailey and Ray Blanchard and so
I happen to have a father who is much
more probably critical and aware of the
evidence and the data around transition
than most people would have so I'm not
sure that my parents would have allowed
me to do some sort of yeah you know
juvenile transition but that's most
people's dads are not sex professors
yeah yeah so okay so you you believe you
that you would have been drawn in that
direction
and I think I think I would have been I
think my parents probably would have
been resistant to it and I would have
pushed you would have pushed which would
puts you at the very least we can say it
would have created a corrosive problem
for your relationship with your parents
or sure and teenagers already have
corrosive relationships with their
parents so this this just would have
been the thing instead of whatever it
was the thing when I was 15 or whatever
and if we Jenna
realize because most people's deaths
don't write teach evolutionary
psychology the toolkit to know how to
even respond to this there's no tool it
there's no tool kit and this raises so
many frightening questions I mean so you
know Heather was absolutely a tomboy
also and I must say one of the things I
think it takes a while to understand
about what Heather and I are saying
about sex and relationships and stuff is
that on the one hand there are some
traditional aspects that I think we're
throwing away too easily the other hand
our relationship isn't traditional at
all it's really symmetrical right right
she's very much the woman I'm very much
the man but you know we play similar
roles in the world so anyway there's a
lot of room to Reena Gate stuff for
modern realities but Heather was a
tomboy she also feels that she would
have been pushed towards trans in the
modern era and the fact is you're gay
mm-hmm
she's not gay right I don't think either
if you were born in the wrong body no
right you've both reached this
conclusion now is body still function
clear-headed adults say and so the point
is there is this it's it's knee-jerk
there's this knee-jerk thing over on the
authoritarian left where it's like we've
got a litmus test right if you do not
subscribe to this thing then it is
because of this motive right and so
anybody who resists anything trans is a
trans folk right right
the problem is trans is in tension
therefore with gay and with straight
tomboy yes right
so the problem is you've got
historically oppressed people in three
different categories whose interests are
yeah right there has to be an adult
solution to this where we acknowledge
there are trans people not everybody who
presents in some non-standard way is
trans there's you know as you're also
variation right right it's it's a
complex scenario with a bunch of
different dip switches and we get every
combination right and all of them as far
as I know all of them are valid but a
simple-minded rubric that forces people
and are you following a natalie win
doctor points yeah she's not a fan of
mine but yes interest she i wrote about
her she was invited to UBC and vancouver
to do a talk with claire white you know
and there was of course day this is
several years ago there was of course a
huge conflagration [ __ ] show response to
that and i wrote about and defended her
you know willing to go have a
conversation with a conservative trans
woman and we had a nice sort of dialogue
and then her you know she sort of
through jesse single under the bus sort
of weird internet drama stuff so I'm a
fan of Paradis but I don't think that
it's mutual not mutual yeah well I guess
I have I have also seen her react in
ways that I don't think are sensible
relative she's in a difficult position
extremely difficult right and you know
this recent episode with her where she
had what's his name buck no buck angel
[ __ ] [ __ ] it yeah do a 12-second
voice over for one of her I think rather
remarkable videos and she got skewered
for being you know they're too made-up
terms I guess trans-med trans medical
assistant Transcom Isabel yeah and it's
like okay you've made up these two terms
and you've set some sort of tripwire and
you know and contra points tripped over
your trip wire and now you're gonna
skewer and buck I mean so buck is a buck
as a friend of mine buck was in this
piece that I read about D transition
years ago that he was he also vetted it
before it was published so buck is a
trans guy who is was on the forefront
for forefront he was one of the earliest
people to have table surgery
he's done remarkable work sort of
talking about you know he calls himself
the man with the vagina he really
embraced it embraces his body and he's
so he's an old-school transsexual I
think natalie is too and the tension
between the old-school transsexuals and
the new-school transgenders is just
remarkable these are just these two
groups are at odds with each other they
have different goals one wants to
abolish gender and one wants to actually
just appears the opposite sex right you
know passing would be the goal not to
sort of say like so you have a situation
like that where you have you know a
bunch of Liberals or whatever
progressive staying around talking about
you know mostly straight people probably
says people you know talking about their
pronouns and there's the one trans
person in the group who then has to it
becomes a sort of excuse for us all to
talk about pronouns when really all that
person wants is just to fit in well the
seams so I mean admittedly I'm you know
I'm in the easiest position here I must
you know a straight guy yeah the the
required privilege disclaimer here yeah
well I'm not even using it as a
disclaimer I'm just saying from the
point of view of my figuring out what
these other positions that people are in
are I have the easiest right role yeah
straight married guy you know
pretty much nobody's gonna trouble me on
this front but but let me ensure if
you're real quick there so there is this
there's this other there's a lot of
people like you who are straight married
guys who look like you beards short hair
pants all the sort of trappings of being
male who have decided that they're not
male now either that they are non-binary
or gender this or a gender or whatever
and nothing they haven't changed their
physical presentations nothing in their
lives have changed still married to the
woman still have the kids all they've
said to the world is I don't want my
power I don't want my privilege yeah
give me this give me this special
pronoun and they're not dismantling
gender they're just trying to trying to
opt out of it themselves because they
feel bad about their own privilege or
whatever yeah they've bought this sort
of central line inside of the
authoritarian left pantheon that says
that the thing to do if you regard
yourself as having honor and privilege
just to give it away right which is
pointless right attic Lee
not even possible you giving it away
doesn't give it to somebody else right
or I'll take it right or if you do give
it away you will end up giving it away
to the people in the category in the
category or at least deserving being
right there out there collecting other
people's privilege okay so what I would
say first of all I have a response to
this which is I do believe that unearned
privilege is a problem but I believe
that if you have some the thing that you
should do is spend it honorably spend
your honor and privilege honorably right
and I try to do this but anyway from the
perspective of somebody who has none of
these problems in my right right I do
think the solution on the question of
trans medical ISM trans come mm-hmm
buck angel all of this is pretty
straightforward let us just admit that
the truth of trans is complex and nobody
knows what it is it is it I mean it is
incredibly complex I mean a lot of sex
researchers argue that's an orientation
right you know or you know which is an
incredibly unpopular position to take
one that got you know ray Lancer didn't
mike baillie
dragged in the 90s and early 2000s sure
so if it is true though that it is
complex and nobody's got it nailed yet
then relax and stop dragging people over
opinions right fact is Natalie when is
entitled to an opinion yeah on trans
medical ISM if it was now she's not of
this opinion but were she it doesn't
invalidate who she is as a person now I
don't know if she will see this I kind
of hope that she will I would say to her
that I think she is badly misunderstood
by the world and she is not doing
herself any favors by burning people
like you and me and Jesse single who
actually do appreciate what she's up to
oh I agree with you I mean that's sort
of my interest in her is because she
besides the fact that she does amazing
work you know she's really lifted up
viewed as a hero by this group that also
doesn't seem to get her or even liked
her when she when she steps out of line
and to me that's the interesting two
position at the end because it can be so
transformative yeah but you have people
like I you know I I think Lena Dunham is
in this category someone who is hated
for lots of reasons some of them legit
some of them not but instead of sort of
using absorbing that criticism
transforming it and becoming a more
empathetic person a more tolerant person
a more open-minded person I'm a person
we're willing to cross these arbitrary
ideological lines what she does instead
is become a bully that's what I can't
stand when you are when you have gone
through something that like you've gone
through where I've gone through or
anybody's gone through and and it just
hardens you and cuz it you're talking
about Lena Dunham Lena Dunham I'm not
talking about I think no I think
Natalie's in the position now where she
could go either way
yeah if she wants to maintain the
audience who has supported her until now
most of which are lots of about trans
folks and their allies well she's got a
choice to make you know if she can be
she can capture keep that audience or
capture anyone well I think the problem
is she is doing two vital things if I
understand what I see correctly one
thing that she is doing is she is in
excruciating detail
allowing people to participate in her
transition to sort of understand how she
thinks about it her own you know
internal conflicts I mean it's amazing
what she's actually put on video and let
us hear you know it's like hearing her
internal monologue as she's on this very
difficult journey right that's
interesting if you care at all about
this trans thing it's not like what
she's describing as general but she's
giving you the window into one person's
experience that is unmatched I think and
the other thing she's doing has almost
nothing to do with trans at all which is
she is a very insightful person who has
a unique capacity to teleport herself
into the mind of somebody with whom she
does not agree and so her little
teleplays and for those who don't know
her work she does these very elaborate
very visually provocative videos in
which
plays all of the characters and the
characters give voice to lots of stuff
including you know she's got an all
right character she's got an
authoritarian left character right she's
got all of these entities and she is
simultaneously lampooning them but also
giving voice to their best arguments
which if you haven't seen it it's
definitely worth paying attention to
because it does for me at least it
provides insight into how these people
view themselves in a very very visually
I don't want to say compelling because
some people will find it repellent
mm-hmm and other people find it
compelling but doing it in a way that it
holds your attention and it's very hard
to dismiss it she's almost you know
there's the criticism that everybody
gets who sort of in our position like I
think Dave Rubin probably gets more than
anybody that you know there's a sort of
guilt by association and if you engage
with anybody who has these ideas whether
it's Candice Onan Owens for Mike's
tournament or whoever you know the
goalposts always moves that your
platforming this person and that is bad
and you can't do that well what she's
doing is it's sort of exactly that but
without that without the added
controversy of the person you mean by
using these characters right by voicing
the characters instead of having Candice
Owens on the show she can do Candice
Owens which really I think saves her
sort of a lot of grief in some ways it
also is visually just really stunning
it's really stunning it's really well
done
yeah and she's multi-talented I mean she
was a I think she bailed out of
philosophy a PhD he said and bailed out
because she couldn't stand it you know
not because she couldn't hack it he's
literally very good at what she does
yeah as a filmmaker I mean I don't know
if she has any training as a filmmaker
but I think she does everything sort of
one camera very few people helping her
it's yeah it is it's really remarkable
she's also a musician right but she then
you know someone like Christina Hoff
Sommers will say something like if
Christina seems like a big fan of
Natalie you know and the response of
that is like from her fans just get your
get her name out of your mouth
yeah it's so anyway I think I think
she's in a very frightening position in
which there is a good move but because
the the KE shift that would occur she
made the move would be massive it's got
to be very frightening from her
perspective sure if she embraced the
wider world people who find value in
what she's doing even beyond the trans
stuff she would lose a bunch of her most
authoritarian radical transfer fanbase
right and she would gain I think she
would gain a world of people outside and
in effect I think she would do a
tremendous service for trans because her
value her primary value is that she's
insightful the fact of a trans person
who is wildly insightful and can enter
into this landscape of new political
entities and you know understand them
well enough to do a play in which she's
doing all the parts that person has a
unique contribution to make and so for
her to be making that contribution and
for that contribution not to be
fundamentally about trans-ness is in
some sense the ultimate defense yeah the
trans community needs really sane trans
people like her and I actually don't
know if she is saying so let me take
that back the trans community needs sane
trance places because right now what's
happening is you know there's these
small issues and and sort of the big
scheme of things you know trans women in
sports this this case in Texas this Luna
/ James kid who is you know going
through this custody battle and the
right-wing media takes these issues and
they mom on to them and it's not hard to
see why because they're interesting and
they're disturbing and this is going to
these two things trans women in sports
and pediatric transition is going to
hurt the trans community because the
right-wing media has attached on to it
and so regular
people who aren't even sort of
right-wingers who do maybe have
objections to transwoman and sports in
pediatric transition if they want to go
get information on it they can go to
Breitbart they can go to the federalists
they can go to these like tea party
blogs where they can't go is the New
York Times or slate or most mainstream
publications who are just parroting the
sort of most outrageous claims like
trans women are female trans women get
periods you know these things that any
sort of normal person can look at and
say this is [ __ ] oh you're exactly
right and the presidential candidates
are doing it I mean the presidential
candidates at the LGBTQ CNN Town Hall
which should not have happened in the
first place this is a terrible idea they
kept talking about the quote-unquote
epidemic of murder or the the the
epidemic of trans homicides right the
epidemic is 20 people yeah this is not
an epidemic this isn't even higher this
isn't isn't even disproportionately high
rates of murder and most of the people
who've murdered have been black trans
women and the the murder rates are
actually lower than that of black males
right so this is not like there is an
effort there is a murder epidemic and
it's black males this is not it's just
it doesn't make any sense everybody can
see it and when politicians and the left
continue to pair at these lines they're
driving people into the right oh
absolutely
you're taking a group of people that has
a difficult for sure a difficult fight
and you are fusing them to arguments
that are so obviously backwards and
confused and what's more it's not even
that this is abstract most of us who
aren't trans like there's a force that
wants to argue that if Mike child shows
signs of you know feeling like the other
sex that I am obligated to not only
endorse this but that surgery
I mean irreversible stuff okay you want
to this is stuff that gets to the very
core right like I am not in favor of a
world in which
we are forced to defend our rights with
guns but when you start talking about
coming after people's children and
permanently altering them surgically
based on what could be evidence of a
permanent state of mind or it can be
faced or it could be a phase you know
childhood is confusing you at the very
least need to grapple with the fact that
lots of people who go through some phase
come out of it it straightens out on
their own and you have no right to
transition those people so yes you are
right this is the naive full-strength
position nothing but a full embrace of
everything trans including former men
competing against women in sports and
you know former men going to prison even
if they've just it's mind-boggling never
even having this discussion right you
know so I'd learned something
interesting recently so there are these
clinicians sort of there's a few very
famous clinicians in the US who are
really at the forefront of things like
pediatric transition they run their own
gender clinics you know they have lots
of supporters so one of them is in San
Francisco her name I'm going to butcher
her last name it sign trough or
something like that Dianna Jeff and I
see these I see a lot of parallels with
what's happening right now with previous
moral panics you know the satanic panic
of the 1980s the the the false you know
a daycare and skander's right now right
so there's you know some of the forces
are the same too like you know they're
feminists like MS magazine and in like
1990 had a the cover of MS magazine said
there's a picture of a like a devil and
it said like Santa satanic ritual abuse
is real believe them you know if there
had been a hashtag it would have just
been it could have been right now all
right so this woman in San Francisco
Diana I trap one of the one of the
foremost gender clinic people prefer
motive transition she talks about you
know if your if your three-year-old
pulls the throw out of her hair she
might actually be a boy [ __ ] like that
so in the 80s or 90s she wrote a paper
that recently came to light about
hell satanic ritual abuse is real so
it's not just sort of the same sort of
vague feeling like we're in a moral
panic then we've seen this before it's
the same people yeah well there is there
is something to this it's more it's more
than an analogy right it's the same
people sometimes I'm reminded when the
Evergreen thing went down I remember
speaking of it as a witch time when I
took a certain amount of flack for that
as you would imagine and then later it
emerged that a few days before the
protest at my classroom the guy who had
organized it had posted to his Facebook
page a you know one of these Facebook
things where you get a color and then
you get why it's basically like Twitter
for face but it he posted something to
the effect of never have white men hid
from the shadows of themselves and a
witch hunt or something like he was
clearly planning a witch hunt even he it
was a wig hairy but a virtue eight
switched on I'm sure in his mind well
maybe not but that's the amazing thing
is you know to me witch hunt is an
indictment the very term because there
are no witches the iPod oh yeah now I've
read to something in like Forbes or
something less was about something it's
in there was some some stupid Halloween
article about you how you shouldn't
dress up as a witch because my 11th my
grandmother going back in the belief the
nation in the nation of course you know
my grandmother going back to Leavitt
generations was an actual witch and the
New York Times I published a piece in
which they interviewed a witch I mean it
was the most absurd which is wishes are
a thing now which is are also immune you
know I mean there is astrology is in
witches are an it's all it's all very
aggravating to me that is that the sort
of same people who you know believe in
climate change say they believe in
science believe in evolution things like
this also believe that you know the
position of the stars at the moment of
your birth is why your dentist or
whatever yeah aggravating wick if your
dentist was into astronomy yeah yeah
it's a it's a well I don't know there is
sort of a
there is evidence of widespread
confusion yes at the moment and I wonder
I wonder what its Genesis really is
well this to me it seems cyclical you
know this is not the first time and it
will not be the last time you know I
keeps coming back to a couple of things
which is just sort of the viral nature
of human behavior with the trans stuff
which with actual witch hunts with the
satanic panic you know it we take ideas
and we spread them and now we have the
internet so we don't even have to do it
in person yes although I also think
there is something to be said for you
know and I don't know how far back this
goes the Internet is the maybe the
version of this with the least viscosity
but these new modes of communicating are
not anticipated by our evolutionary
wiring and they result in positive
feedbacks so you know as Douglas Murray
points out suddenly we've forgotten many
things that we fully understood
yesterday like the difference a tree or
the fact that male and female are
distinct categories through any other
yeah exactly yeah right like a were you
to discover that male and female were
not real categories you would certainly
imagine a long period of transition
figuring out what that meant not only
have we not actually discovered anything
of the sort but you are imagined to have
instantly come around to the new wisdom
right right universe does that even
happen all right
yeah so anyway all I'm getting at is
there is a clearly a ghost in the
machine right that ghost in the machine
may have been what scheduled network
television for decades and that now that
goes to the Machine is the algorithms
that control certain feed because they
are shaping conversations in ways we
don't understand but to the extent that
as you point out people who believe in
climate change are also you know have
renewed interest in tarot cards or
whatever it is
the whole thing is evidence of not
having any idea what the [ __ ] to believe
yeah yeah yeah I think it's I think it's
that I mean I think is sort of man's
eternal quest for meaning and
explanation and I also think part of it
is just straight-up viral it's just like
it's just like a unit you know it's just
a it's a meme and the same way that
golden doodles were more popular than
they were 20 years ago or babies names
or whatever the fact that you know I can
go to the dog park now and every child
is named like kale and sunny and every
dog is named George and Frank like part
of this to me also just seems like just
the absolute nature of human connection
which is taking one idea and passing it
on okay which raises maybe the most
important question for people like you
and me it is after World War Two there
was a period of time in which social
science was actually pretty productive
and it was focused on the question of
how the Nazis happen mm-hmm how the
Holocaust had occurred and the Milgram
experiment in particular which was run
many different ways ultimately has this
been has Milgram yet been uh has been
hit by the replication crisis yet or do
we still trust this one I still trust
this what I frankly even if it were hit
by the rock you still trust it I believe
I know it to be true that through
personal experience having seen you say
that yeah I'm a foal so anyway I'm gonna
yeah you'll have a green version of Lord
of the Flies great experiment yeah all
that stuff 1984 yeah but anyway the
there is something to the idea that the
vast majority of people are wired such
that they do not have the ability to
refuse certain kinds of authority sure
and some of us aren't wired this way at
all okay right I'm in it so the kids
with the authority issues turn out not
to be so easily persuaded by some of
this new received wisdom right right now
there are errors I'm convinced
that there are eras in which those kids
with the authority issues that is people
like you and me are out of place mm-hmm
right that's not the job of the moment
their job is to go along right right it
needs doing right and then there are
other moments when those are the only
people who can think straight because
there's so much of this steering going
on through these other mechanisms that
anybody who's at all susceptible to it
is persuaded of wrong stuff and it's you
know I joke sometimes that zombie movies
are really about preparing people for
what their neighbors look like when
they're starving yeah you know it's that
but it's also I you know I do sort of
have the sense of like there's a there's
a zombie movie unfolding around us and
it has to do with bad software programs
that are spreading virally and causing
people to embrace stuff that they're
conscious mind should know better than
but internally their fears allow them to
be captured all right so I guess the
question is from one kid with an
authority issue to another what do we do
that's the question I mean I feel like
there's another problem here right which
is like all right so you have people
without people like us the kids with the
authority issues I think Allen Trager
would probably say the galilean you know
personality types so let's take Jordan
Peterson for example I recently saw the
you know this Jordan Pederson
documentary the riots of Jordan Peterson
that is pissed some people off who
haven't seen the movies been cancelled
in various venues when it was being shot
in Portland you know and Tifa threatened
to bring out the guillotine and in
response to this movie that was being
shown at a church in the suburbs because
they don't go they don't go out to the
suburbs you know and and so as I was
watching this I mean I've always been
sort of one of those people who thought
that the the reaction to Peterson is
outsized it's the criticism of him is
counterproductive if the goal is to shut
him down and that he's not dangerous and
that's his message is one of sort of
basic common sense
independence you know OMA conservative
values in some way sort of small C
conservative values you know take care
of yourself to carry your family
so nothing inherently problematic there
but I watched this movie and so I've
defended him you know I've said he's not
a Nazi he's not it he's he's he's he's
not a threat to the Republic if your
child is watching Jordan Peterson videos
on YouTube don't write an article about
it in the [ __ ] New York Times talking
about your kid being alright like this
is not this is not a step to the all
right if anything is to step away from
it but watching this film this
documentary and you know I've spoken to
a lot of his his followers I do see the
danger there for the first time and the
danger is in the adulation right it's
the fact that yet Peterson might have
good motives and he might be highly
attuned to the fact that what he's
trying to do is resist authoritarianism
he's been obsessed with this his whole
life but his followers or his followers
right and so even if the message is one
of independence and of thinking for
yourself and not following along with
the crowd most people are gonna follow
along with the crowd and so I don't even
so if even if you're telling people
don't listen to me think for yourself I
don't think you can do that I think that
what they're gonna do it's just a sort
of fandom well I think you that's the
perfect response actually and for my
listeners who don't know
Jordan Peterson was in Seattle and I
called you up and was like do you want
to go yeah when I went yeah thing
together and then you wrote an article
about it which was in some ways I mean
it was a tough article you were you were
not easy on him but I thought it was a
very decent article in the sense that
what she said if I remember it correctly
is I Katie Hertzog don't need Jordan
right Orson my real clean I don't yeah
my room is clean that's good but he is
not what he is being portrayed right not
funny he's a deprecating he's decent etc
yeah and I think that this is a message
a lot of people needed to hear and I
wish that that piece had gotten wider
circulation
but you're exactly right about Jordan is
a decent guy right a lot of what he's
saying is common sense and the part
that's not common sense is carefully
thought out and it is about decency
right that's like a core mission of his
I'm convinced of that as somebody who
knows him pretty well
the followers if Jordan were a bad guy
we'd be in big trouble that exactly
exactly yeah thank goodness he's not
right right right and I don't know what
happens if something happens to him and
that movement is captured right but for
the moment let us not freak out and let
us say actually thank goodness that
somebody you know I do think he's too
backwards looking mm-hmm all right he's
looking for us to go back to a place
that we can't go back to right but the
point is pay attention to what you're
doing you're hurting yourself stop it
and it clearly works at an individual
level absolutely lots of people are
getting a lot of benefit from it and it
is the alternative to one of these
corrosive destructive not what they say
movements so so I believe the caution is
exactly the right one
there's nothing frightening about
Peterson but there is something
frightening about if he was not what he
appeared to be what that moved right and
you can say that about anybody you can
say that about Roxane gay you can say
that about anybody I mean this really
it's just the nature of fandom but I
think that's the problem is like you
have people like us who maybe are a
little bit more
I don't know resistant to the call of
authority but most people aren't like us
Yeah right so we can you and I can get a
big following and sort of preach our
values to these people and maybe they
would listen to us and and uphold what
we think are you know the correct
classical liberal values tolerance
diversity of thought but that doesn't
mean that people are going to absorb the
wider message or if they're just going
to be following along and I don't know
an answer to that I mean I think that's
what Peterson is trying to do is to
teach people to resist a call of the
right Arianism and groupthink yeah but I
don't know how it works I mean you know
Orwell was writing about this in the 40s
people were writing about it before then
it's just it's the conundrum
I dunno though after going through all
of this what I do know is that you know
when I was a kid and you know we studied
the Holocaust in schools and I would
think like you know of course I would be
the one to resist the Nazis absolutely I
know that now yep I think she did I know
that too yeah which is ironic because
I'm called a Nazi all the time all the
time
yeah the irony's never stopped at the
authoritarian laughter I agree yeah what
I think needs to be said is it you know
it feels very good to know what you
wouldn't be a collaborator the problem
is we would very probably be dead
because of that right right it's not
like it works out in the end
as you would resist there were there was
a resistance there was a resistance and
there were uprising right and look you
know and they were free there were hate
speech laws I didn't stop the Holocaust
from happening absolutely I think though
there there is a kind of evolutionary
subtext to all of this that I don't
think has been well explored yet and
holds the answer to what you're getting
at and what it has to do with is the
fact that people in general are kind of
prone to herd-like behavior and it's
very frightening because it does end up
in things like the Holocaust they also
have another mode though I'm not sure
absolutely everybody does but I think
it's in everybody at some level even you
know if it beat if it's dormant too long
maybe it can't be awaken but the
question really is how do we behave in
such a way as to wake the part of people
that actually will resist you know a
Jordan Peterson who isn't well
intentioned right example right and it's
a tough it's a tough problem because you
know if you make that the message
wake up and don't follow too easily you
know it's Monty Python right you know
right you don't have to follow anyone
you are all individuals right we are all
and Dustin doctrine ate them with the
with the message that they are all
individual right exactly but and you
know there's another thing I don't know
how seriously to take it but for people
in my generation the matrix had a
special meaning and in fact I am kind of
annoyed that red pill I have been stolen
from us as a metaphor because it's kind
of a necessary one and it has nothing to
do with one side or the other
politically but one of the things in the
matrix is you're not supposed to wake
people past a certain age they can't
handle it right now I don't know that a
certain age is really what we're talking
about but there is a question about the
ability to wake becomes more complex the
more stuff that you have stacked upon a
particular received set of wisdom and I
do think that we should be trying to
figure out how to wake people but I
think we also need to be aware that that
carries dangers that we don't know
because in general most people are you
know not highly cognizant right right so
I don't know what to do about it but but
we are sort of stuck in that puzzle yeah
I think the more people who stand up
it's a better position we'll be in but
you know as you know it comes with a lot
of personal costs it does that article
that that came out of the New York Times
that talked about this question actually
do you want to say anything about that
article um I don't have that much to say
about it I mean there so this article
for the listeners this article came out
in the New York Times last week it was
written by a guy named John McDermott I
think it was called like those people we
tried to cancel they're all hanging out
together and I was in a Jesse single
Dave Rubin christina hoff sommers I
think maybe not Alice Trager sort of the
people you know our tribe I suppose but
the reality is like for one thing the
headline is [ __ ] none of us are
hanging out together
I'm the we tried to cancel the they put
a lot of emphasis on that
I thought that the piece was a little
strange I thought it tried to fit a
narrative that doesn't truly exist
because the reality is there are tons of
professional networks and having a
common experience with someone does not
make you best friends or anything like
that but it is also true that you know
when a when I see someone sort of going
through the ringer on Twitter I do reach
out to them not all not always but often
yeah and offer a few words and I think
it's true that there's gonna be
something really transformative about it
which other people spoke about but still
the piece was a little bit weird there
was like a line in it that said
something like you know Katy Herzog is
part of an emerging group of journalists
thinkers public figures whatever who've
been canceled for having bad
conservative or offensive opinions
yes which was your case it's all three
oh yeah all three I only have that
conservative or offensive opinions so
that line was aggravating yeah because
this idea that you know the only reason
any of us have been through this because
we were wrong as opposed to right yeah
that's it seemingly had not occurred to
their editors well I should say first of
all McDermott reached out oh did he and
to Eric oh I could have to Eric first
actually and you know there's always a
question yeah and they reach out is this
one safe great and in this case we
talked about it and decided no decided
it was not safe yeah so my I had a lot
of conversations in the back channel
with other people he'd approached we
were all talking about that and after
speaking with him my feeling was that I
trusted him because he and I seem to be
on the same page I don't trust the
editors of the paper and I especially do
not trust the editors of the Style
section so that was my concern the whole
time was that a red pen was going to get
introduced and my photo was in the paper
and I told I told John I said if you
know if you if it is if it comes out
that this is this paper this is going to
make like paint us all is not these are
members of the KKK
I will revoke you know your might your
permission to use my photo but the the
idea of you know triggering all my
girlfriends was too powerful so
I just I could imagine someone who like
really doesn't like me you know opening
up the sunday New York Times and seeing
the photo and I just could not resist my
ego just got so cut and then I didn't
like the [ __ ] picture anyway so it
was a good pick oh thank you yeah
so I did want to say something about it
is is that I think that there's a I got
into a back-and-forth on Twitter about
it and I said something which triggers
people every time I say it which is
there's a dangerous message in telling
people that you know those who have been
cancelled are actually hanging out
together right it's a very powerful
inducement to people right to stand up
and the problem is I do want people to
stand up whenever Green happened Heather
and my point to our colleagues was you
know if we all stand up they can't do it
right and didn't happen one right one
person and now he's the only person like
you busy with now but but anyway my
point is two things one we don't know
how many people have been cancelled and
never heard from totally right we don't
know how often that happens and so we
have a survivor bias issue that's a
statistical term meaning that we see
certain data points and we don't see
others right right you know we see the
fossils of creatures that were
widespread we don't see the fossils of
ones that never got to a large
population size for example so if you
interview the people who somebody tried
to cancel and now they go to the
heterodox Academy meetings and a podcast
and have podcasts on things you're
liable to get a very wrong picture of
this is only what kind of life you will
lead on the other side and those of us
who are in this position I believe has
have a near sacred obligation to tell
the truth to those who are contemplating
what to do and yes I do want them to
stand up but I do not want them to stand
up on the basis that it is safe or
glamorous on the other side because it
might be but it probably won't be and
what we need are people who are ready
for life in the [ __ ] foxhole and if
you're not ready for life in the [ __ ]
foxhole you're a liability in the
foxhole right so we can't
have that so anyway what I would say to
those who are contemplating what message
to broadcast about this don't downplay
the dangers and don't take the
responsibility for other people and say
yes you should stand up telling if
you're not going to be there for them
when [ __ ] goes south yeah right so that
when people do make this decision if
you've been honest with them when they
even they do make the decision to stand
up then eh they're taking responsibility
for what happens and be they'll be more
robust in the face of what comes back at
them yeah the worst thing which I now
see too regularly is somebody
I'll make some effort in the direction
of standing up something will come back
at them and then they retreat and it's
like oh you're making things worse don't
don't do that right I never apologize
yeah in this particular case I apologize
when you're you know yeah never
apologize when you're not right wrong
right right don't apologize to get out
of the situation but I actually think
it's very powerful to the extent that we
are all out here playing a very complex
game with unwritten rules we do make
mistakes
mhm absolutely very powerful if you
demonstrate that it's not that you're
constitutionally against apology its
secured against using apology for
expedience right yeah then being well
admitting that you're wrong is is so
interesting because it's this it can be
this intensely painful experience you
know it's sort of a just an ego blow to
say like I was wrong about that but all
it does is increase the perception of
you from the other side or from whoever
you're in dialog with people like it
when other people admit that they're
wrong
that's a it shows a level of maturity
and sort of flexibility and good
judgements and yet it is a very
difficult emotional experience to go
through well I think because if you said
well it elevates you in people's eyes
when you admit that you were wrong so
you know do it a lot right then people
don't trust you right because then the
point of how you're wrong you're doing
it right or you're doing it knowing that
you have a get-out-of-jail-free card
right but if you
reserve it if you're very careful so
that you don't have to apologize very
often but you do it readily when you
need to then that creates the right the
illusion of being a really good person
hell yeah even if what you say yeah
conservative conservative and bad and
belly yeah just bad powerful words
they're bad that's partially redundant
well I guess John McDermott didn't get
you in the piece but we are actually
hanging out so he was a so he's wrong
about that one the writers I guess we
are hanging out so there there's that
yeah yeah all right cool well this has
been a very interesting discussion I'm
always pleased to talk with you it's
never exactly what I expect it's always
enlightening though oh I feel the same
way thanks for having me let you thank
you
so people can find you you're in the
stranger regularly yep first week I'm on
the I write something for the blog every
day so I have a daily deadline a daily
deadline yeah it's uh it's difficult I
was grueling
it is grueling and are you writing while
we're talking I've already written this
morning I actually already had a yeah
I'd like even on even when I'm like down
in Portland on vacation I I already
wrote so yeah I write everyday for the
stranger and I'm active on Twitter at
Kitty purr Zog I can't promise that I
will apologize on Twitter very often but
when I deserve it maybe well I can
promise if past performance is any guide
that you will be wickedly funny both on
Twitter and in the stranger and very
regularly so I highly encourage people
to find you and read your stuff and
anyway thanks so much for being on the
Dark Horse podcast and I look forward to
our next conversation yeah thanks for
having me
[Applause]